- My brother was a disk jockey
and he built his own radio station.
And he would play all
these incredible albums
from the late '60s.
And of course he played
the "Let it Be" album.
- Yeah.
And he played "Across the Universe,"
and I must have been four years old.
And I remember being frozen, paralyzed,
listening to that music.
♪ Pools of sorrow, waves of joy ♪
And it just, it's my
favorite song ever written.
- It's so beautiful.
- Which is why I'm gonna announce
some big news for everybody.
- Wait, what?
- I'm gonna have a little girl.
- I know that.
I know that! Oh!
(audience cheering)
I knew you were having a baby,
I didn't know it was a girl!
- Yeah.
And her name, because of
"Across the Universe,"
her name is gonna be Lennon, Lennon Augie.
Augie after my father.
And I'll call her Lenny
for short, but yeah.
- I love that.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- That's so exciting.
- Yeah, I'm thrilled.
- You're gonna be a girl dad.
- It's gonna be the biggest
adventure of my life.
So here we go.
- [Kelly] I love that.